ja ich begrüße sie vielmals zur letzten
sitzung dieses seminars in diesem jahr
und wir haben uns für diese letzte
sitzung das ganz besonderes vorgenommen
nämlich wir werden uns mit zwei ganz
wichtigen mittelalterlichen philosophen
oder theologen war damals sehr verwandt
diese beiden rollen die beiden
disziplinen beschäftigen und zwar zuerst
mit diesem netten herrn hiermit duns
scotus scotus heißt der kam aus
schottland und ich habe ihn ja so ein
paar zitat herumgeschickt das war zu
einem experiment die schwierigkeit
besteht beim mittelalterlichen denkern
darin dass die meistens gar nicht so ein
zusammenhängendes werk geschrieben haben
was sich jetzt als seminar grundlage
eignet sein muss da immer mal ein
bisschen das ganze werk durchforsten und
schauen welche zitate passen aus diesem
sehr umfangreichen werk besonders gut zu
unserem thema das habe ich gemacht und
ich habe ihn auch immer die lateinischen
entsprechung mit geschickt und wir
wollen uns also heute fassen mit uns
coaches und in der zweiten hälfte des
seminars wollen wir uns mit thomas von
aquin beschäftigen
auch da habe ich ihn mir ein paar zitate
vorher zu gewichten
jetzt haben wir ein paar leitfragen die
habe ich auch schon vorhin an die wand
geworfen kurz ganz simpel einmal wie
verhalten sich wille und vernunft nach
bund scotus zueinander
also es wird in dieser sitzung heute
immer um dieses verhältnis gehen will ja
weißt sind von ihnen jemand was auf
lateinisch als wir sind jetzt im
lateinischen nicht mehr wiener letzten
sitzung bei aristoteles im griechische
was die nach uns coaches und den ganzen
mittelalterlichen denkt an die auf
lateinisch geschrieben haben will heißt
jetzt ganz verschiedene möglichkeiten
freiwillige vor war das eine meldung
nicht will jan
genau als ich mache das jetzt mal so wir
sammeln jetzt einfach mal darf ich mal
fragen mehr von ihnen datei kenntnisse
besitzt einfach mal melden wer so ein
bisschen rudimentär
das sind doch eigentlich fast alle das
ist ja schon mal gut aber selbst wenn
man sie nicht hat ist nicht schlimm
wir wollen hier ja auch primär die
deutschen texte ins zentrum stellen also
ist wurde die hand die wohl und
harmonisierungen der das wort volition
kommt von wohl und aß das kommt
natürlich von welchem lateinischen
infiniti wohl unter welchem lateinischen
intuitiv was ist das verb wäre ja wähle
wähle
und dann ist der ablauf ist zum beispiel
im perfekt wo louis und da haben wir
dann den stamm vertrieb nominal bildung
ok wohl und haas also der wille und wir
haben genannt noch abitur ab wie triumph
hatten wir glaube ich in der letzten
sitzung ein bisschen drüber diskutiert
was erinnern sie sich noch was kann
alles atrium bedeuten
denken sie mal in englisch paar bilder
anbieter schon mal jörg-peter manche
leute verwenden dieses wort um
schiedsrichter zu benennen
der referee
um den arbeiter oder kann es also
lateinisch gibt es auch noch anbieter
das ist sollen der schiedsrichter als
atrium wie könnte man das dann benennen
wenn es das vermögen des schiedsrichters
ist was sein vermögen ist es dann
es mögen des schiedsrichters
schiedsrichter zu sein
das muss der schiedsrichter machen
können um ein schiedsrichter
schiedsrichter zu sein
richter ja oder also richten ist
durchaus gut urteil fällen genau er muss
ein urteil fällen
ja
ja auch er muss mit regeln umgehen
können genau oder muss auch entscheiden
können
also war das jetzt abseits oder nicht so
faul oder nicht von der als alle punkte
die sie genannt haben sind richtig
einmal könnte es also häufig wird das
übersetzt mit entscheidungs vermögen
entscheidung sammeln sie kennen das
deutsche wort antwort abitur hat von
ihnen jemand literaturwissenschaften
studiert er studiert jemand von ihm auch
literaturwissenschaften gibt es jemand
einfach mal melden haben sie bestimmt
auch mal linguistik gehabt ein bisschen
linguistik und wenn sie dann semantik
glaube ich symantec machen dann gibt es
dieses wort abitur bei zeichen jetzt im
zeichensysteme die semiotik und dann
geht es darum dass man sagt ich habe ein
laut bild zum beispiel katze ich habe
ein weder ein zeichen das tue ich jetzt
mal die anstriche schreiben eigentlich
eigentlich bräuchte ich gar nicht im
fünf schreien schicken und ich habe noch
so ein laut bild
vielleicht zu ich bin kein chemiker ich
bin kein egoist katze
und dann habe ich hier sieht stürzen
indem gottesanbeterin eine katze die
katze ich denke man kann so halbwegs
erkennen es sieht eher aus wie ein
walross in die kreuzung aus walross und
gottesanbeterin und dieses zeichen dass
laut bild katze oder das zeichen ktzg
referiert auf die katze in der welt und
jetzt sagt man in der semiotik dieser
bezug hier das jetzt katzen auf
referiert das ist abb
das ist petra kodré heißt es ist
beliebig jetzt entweder also es könnte
auch anders man hat sie jetzt eben
festgelegt dass katze zu nennen dieses
wesen hier das seltsame wesen hier
dass es eben auch betrieb das heißt es
gibt immer die tendenz dass atrium oder
abi trier auch als die willkür zu
verstehen ist die willkür
ich habe schon oft gesagt willkürlich
muss jetzt nicht schlecht das bedeutet
wenn man heute sagt das war doch
willkürlich diese entscheidung die war
doch rein beliebig das war nach
gutdünken dann dann verwendet man will
können negativ aber dem ursprünglichen
wortlaut der ursprünglichen
wortbedeutung zufolge bedeutet willkür
einfach nur bill und co
also es ist die kür und das dafür ist
die wahl sie kennen alle das wort
auserkoren da wurde jemand auserkoren
oder sie kennen wenn sie zum beispiel
sich die olympische spiele man häufig
anschauen dann gibt es dann immer das
dressurreiten das dressurreiten und da
gibt es dann die kür
was ist sind die kühe oder auch beim
schlittschuhlaufen beim eiskunstlauf was
ist sind die kühe
wissen sie was die tür ist also ich
glaube ich weiß ich bin mir auch nicht
sicher
die krise beim eiskunstlauf oder beim
dressur halten ist eine bestimmte option
die nach belieben
gewählt werden kann also
es ist meiner willkür und jemand der die
kühe gutmachte werden auserkoren und der
wird dann eben gekürt zum sieger dieses
eiskunstlaufs oder dieses dressur reiter
und jemand der gekürt wird der wird
natürlich nicht willkürlich gekürt als
in dem sinne dass wir sagen wir werfen
jetzt mal eine münze wäre jetzt der
sieger ist und wie die münze eben dann
am ende ihre kopf oder zahl nach oben
weisen lässt so richten wir uns dann
unsere kühe
da wird jeder sagen das ist doch
willkürlich diese kür nur müsste also
bei einer richtigen kühe müsste man
gründe anführen oder eine diskussion
stattfinden lassen argumente ins spiel
bringen die dafür oder dagegen sprechen
dass jetzt diese person auserkoren wird
als was auch immer muss gründe geben
das wirkt ich wollte irgendwie jetzt nur
dass damit sagen dass er hilft der
willkür in der heutigen zeit eine
bedeutungs verschlechterung erfahren hat
die ziemlich genau mit dem 18
jahrhundert zusammenhängt es gab
ich glaube dass es damit zusammenhängt
dass in dieser zeit ein neuer
freiheitsbegriff entwickelt wurde
der mäher mit selbstbestimmung mit
moralischer selbstbestimmung zu tun hat
im sinne des rechenschaft gebens und
rechenschaft ablegen und
das lieben die willkür dann häufig mit
14 willkür und sonstigen politischen
unsitten in verbindung gebracht wurde
aber an sich ist die willkür nichts
schlimmes und in diesem sinne wollen wir
heute auch uns mit diesem begriff das
atrium lieferung häufig noch lieber um
das heißt nur das frei entscheidungs
vermögen oder das freie wahl vermögen um
uns mit damit befassen
es gibt da viel im bereich des willens
gibt es noch andere begriffe zb den
appetit muss rational ist schreibst du
hin
ich glaube man schreibt im märz
weiterhin eine fähre mit 22 oder appetit
usw
es ist einfach was ist dass der appetit
rationales
was steckt in diesen appetitlos drin
nicht das lateinische wort ich mich ja
infiniti wissen sie dass ich glaube ich
weiß ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ich glaube und das heißt glaube ich
streben oder also das ist praktisch das
strebe vermögen und das ist dass
rational das vernünftige strebe vermögen
vertrieb national antreten
zu antrieb und jetzt haben wir hier noch
die vernunft und was ist da haben sie
mir da mögliche kandidaten lateinischer
sprache ja als ja nicht meldet auch
keine minuten haben sie da eine einen
kandidaten für vernünftiges wort was
vernunft bedeutet
ratio
haben sie noch ein anderes wort es gibt
noch mehrere wörter von missverstand
intelligenz jetzt habe ich schon fast
verraten
genau electus da gibt es eine riesen
debatte deutschen verwenden wir vernunft
und verstand häufig synonym
wir werfen die in einen topf intelligenz
werfen auch noch in einen topf häufig
würde man sagen vernunft und verstand
ist doch dasselbe und intelligenz ist
vielleicht ein bisschen spezifischer so
ist jetzt jedenfalls mein sprach vom
vielleicht deutsche mieter auch aber in
der philosophischen tradition gibt es
eine ganz gravierende unterscheidung
zwischen vernunft und verstand haben sie
eine idee was jetzt von beiden er mit
der vernunft und verstand kommentiert
ist
ändert sich mal mal ins es so mal ist es
so was würden sie jetzt sagen was von
beiden rad zum intellekt tus ist am
ehesten mit dem deutschen wort mit der
deutschen nord bildung von vernunft zu
identifizieren ja würden sie sagen
verstand und 7 grad zu vernunft ja
wobei man eben die haben richtig
rational aber rationalen rationell sind
ja auch sehr eng verwandt und in
deutschland wird das nicht mehr so ganz
klar aber in griechischen gibt es noch
die unterscheidung zwischen news und
zwischen diana und muss wird häufig mit
dem deutschen wort vernunft in
verbindung gebracht also vernunft ist
doch die einsicht in den grund in den
zweck die neue system neues ist mit dem
griechischen wort news verwandt und sie
haben sie noch gemeldet
zu gelten
ja ja genau also wenn sie zu sagen das
ist ein vernünftiger mensch ist halt
doch mal vernünftig dann würde man nicht
sagen seid doch mal wo man könnte schon
sagen zeit auch mal rational auch aber
ich glaube in dem dieser rede mit zeit
einer vernünftig da appelliert man an
eine grund einsicht der person sieht
doch den grund ein und rational hat
immer so auch diese netze rationell was
ist rational was würden sie als
rationell bezeichnen als etwas
rationelle
gibt es ein beispiel für etwas was
rational ist
nur muss man rational seien ja genau
als in der wirtschaft zb als wenn man
zum beispiel bwl vwl studiert dann muss
man eine form von intelligenz oder von
vernunft und rationalität entwickeln die
die ration rationelle sehr gut bedenkt
zum beispiel würde ich jetzt mal sagen
logistik oder auch
unternehmensstrategien
die müssen so rationell sein also
rationell hat so ein bisschen was von
dieser instrumentellen vernunft also
zweck mittel und und kalkulation so was
das geht er in die situation also
verstand wird häufig es gibt dann in der
technologie auch manchmal noch
änderungen aber das ist dann das
griechische diana und das ist die das
ist der news news news und vernunft
dieses nun in dem wort und die dieses
vernunft die sind die weißen eine
etymologische verwandtschaft aus auf
also die sind wirklich die haben so ein
wort geschichtlich haben die wenn ich
mich täusche sind die dran mit einem
indogermanischen in der europäischen
ursprungs wort wir sind deutscher
sprache und griechischer sprache sind
einander verwandt und das ist ungefähr
ich kann es jetzt nicht ganz genau
wiedergeben aber das ist noch so ist der
ursprüngliche die ursprüngliche wurzel
dieser beiden wörtern hat man
rekonstruiert also die in die europäer
auch wenn es die jetzt so nicht gab also
ein um die uhr europäer sozusagen die
man weiß nicht genau woher sie kamen
manche thesen sagen aus russland oder
wie auch immer
also ist erst aus dem gebiet zwischen
dem schwarzen und kaspischen meer gibt
es ganz verschiedene hypothesen dass da
eben viele völker aus diesem bereich
dann nach europa kamen vor paar tausend
jahren und von denen haben sich dann die
verschiedenen sprachen noch abgespalten
und dieses deutsche wort schlafen sagt
zumindest ein ganz bedeutender
altphilologe der wolfgang schadewaldt
der sagt dass das deutsche wort
schnaufen
sie sehen also das ist ein bisschen so
wie das hier schnaufen dass das mit dem
wort vernunft zusammenhängt und er
bringt als beispiel wenn ein pferd
gefahr wittert dann
schnauft es sozusagen ss wittert mit
seinen mit seinen mit seiner nase
wittert es die gefahr
und dieses wittern alle dieses
unmittelbare erkennen einer gefahr oder
einer situation dass es dieses intuitive
direkt erfassen war es mit dem vermögen
des muss oder auch und elektrischen
verbindungen part wird hochinteressant
ob das natürlich heute noch
sprachgeschichtlich bestand haben kann
was der wolfgang schadewaldt gesagt hat
bleibt offen aber ich finde es eine ganz
originelle etymologie ja also können sie
das so merken vernunft hat was mit
schlaufen zu tun
und wer auch wittert wie so ein pferd
mit seinen nüstern etwas wittert der
vita diesen sachverhalt unmittelbar dem
ist das sofort wo ist das hat sowas
müssen mit intuitiver erkenntnis zu tun
und das ist also gerade der news der
muss das haben wir so ein paar sachen
hin gemacht also die die januar ist er
so dieses
dieses diskursive vermögen diskursiv
heißt schritt für schritt zur erkenntnis
zu gelangen
vermittelt über verschiedene schritte
sind kalkulieren er ist dass dann das
dass ich zerlege meinen gedanken kann in
verschiedenen schritte übrigens auch
kant unterscheidet ganz ähnlich auch die
vernunft vom verstand auch die vernunft
in ihrer reinen form ist bekannt etwas
was dieses unmittelbare intuitive
erfassen ein bisschen hat bei ihm ist es
moralisch gewendet der verstand ist
verkannt etwas was auch diskursiv
abläuft der verstand ist das denken in
kausalitäten also was war die ursache
von dem also mittel zweck denken ist
auch ihr verstand und die vernunft ist
bekannt dass was diese unmittelbaren
zugriff hat das absolute auch denken
kann die ganzen vernunft ideen gehen
aufs erste und letzte und nicht auf
mittel zweck wie nationalität und das
ist wie gesagt hier intuitiv oder auch
unmittelbar
dieses unmittelbare erfassen das
erfassen ok und das ist als eine frage
und eine andere frage ist wie verhalten
sich wille und vernunft nach thomas von
aquin zueinander
[Applaus]
und jetzt gehen wir einfach mal hier
mitten hinein
die spannende frage ist jetzt also wie
diese zwei vermögen wie sich die
zueinander frage ich sie noch mal erst
mal abstrakt bevor wir die texte lesen
als vor überlegung wie müssen sich der
wille unvernunft einander verhalten
damit wir willens frey genannt werden
können anders gefragt welches vermögen
ist wichtiger um frei genannt zu werden
zu können
jetzt machen wir zwei gruppen ich teile
sie jetzt mal in willkürlich in zwei
gruppen
wir haben jetzt hier in der rechte
gruppe von mir aus gesehen ist die
fenster gruppe da können sie auch noch
mit dazu und sie gehören zur wand gruppe
wo jetzt möchte ich dass ich mal drei
minuten lang gedanken machen und zwar
die fenster gruppe ist die willens
gruppe und die wand gruppe ist vernunft
gruppe und sie versuchen jetzt mal
gründe anzuführen warum eben entweder
bei ihm die vernunft oder bei ihnen der
wille das entscheidende vermögen für
unsere willensfreiheit ist also
verstehen sie die frage dass sie sagen
warum sollte es jetzt der wille sein der
das entscheidet er ist bei der
willensfreiheit und sie versuchen gründe
dafür anzugeben warum es die vernunft
ist macht man das mal so können sie
vielleicht auch ein bisschen an gesetzen
machen es nur ganz kurz drei minuten und
am ende sammeln wir und ging eine
diskussion über
wir sagen wir können jetzt einfach die
ergebnisse gemeinsam mal sammeln
fangen wir an bei der fenster gruppe bei
der willens gruppe welche argumente
hatten sie dafür dass der wille die
entscheidende instanz das entscheidende
vermögen dabei ist wenn es um die frage
nach der freiheit des willens gehen
bitte
die gefahren
ja
ok also box haben sie noch ein anderes
argument noch ähnlich da ich glaube es
geht schon alles in die richtige
richtung noch andere argumente für den
willen
vielleicht können sie das praxis noch
ein bisschen genauer erläutern was damit
gemeint ist schon richtig aber so an das
wort für praxis
wir handeln oder handlung aber
vielleicht noch was anderes was muss da
sein um frei zu sein
ja genau genau sehr gut also aktivität
ist was wie energie auch so ein bisschen
energie realisierung der wille ist da so
ein vermögen was auch seine kraft hat in
sich kraft sollte ich auch noch hin
schreiben
jetzt die band gruppe zum begriff der
vernunft was haben sie dort für
argumente dafür dass die vernunft die
entscheidende instanz bei der
willensfreiheit ist
century diskutiert haben sind doch
bestimmt den einen und anderen möglichen
grund gefunden
was könnten sie jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen als streitgespräch gegen die
willens gruppe a anführen sagt jetzt wir
brauchen den willen weil wir haben wir
dadurch die praxis die handlung energie
etwas zu tun was könnten sie jetzt aus
der perspektive fünfter gegen ein wird
warum es nicht nur der wille ist oder
vielleicht warum sogar ihr die vernunft
das entscheidende ist bitte
gut genau dann könnten sie sagen das ist
doch bloße begierde neuer wille das ist
doch was rational ist und wir keine
vernunft haben und dann leer lasst ihr
euch treiben von euren wünschen von
euronatur wie es eben gerade so ist das
kann man doch nicht frei nehmen dass
seit er abhängig von eurem natur von
antrieben da werden wir gerade nicht
frei ohne vernunft so wird um freiheit
oder nicht mehr abwägen können
wieso haben wie sollen wir das jetzt
hier formulieren hier erkenntnis oder
was würden sie sagen welchen punkt soll
ich hier ein schreiben das ist das
wichtige der vernunft für die freiheit
gründe ja genau gründe behandlungs
gründe
gründe oder motive das hat man sich
glaube ich auch motive ja ja
es fehlen noch
würden diese weise tausende
die fähig wäre das weltbild
genau selbstreflexion oder auch
selbstbestimmung die frage jetzt kann
man sich nicht auch nur willentlich
selbst bestimmen
das sind wichtige punkte sie sagen jetzt
volition zweiter stufe
was sagt die willens gruppe dazu werden
schreibt position zweiter stufe
ausbilden
sagen sie jetzt dazu müssten sie jetzt
dazu sagen wenn sie jetzt dagegen
argument bringen wollen
sagen wir wollen einen wilden bleiben
[Musik]
genau das ist doch alles das ist doch
schon wille hier
das muss doch hier rüber wir haben doch
gesagt welle und so kommt es darüber was
könnten sie jetzt wieder sagen warum
kommt eine volition zweiter stufe nicht
zur seite des willen zu fünft haben
[Musik]
sie sagen also ausbilden
kommt ihr könnt es nur durch die
vernunft durch selbstreflexion harry
frankfurt ich weiß nicht ob sich noch
daran erinnern oder ob wir dieses hat
auch ausführlich diskutiert hatten aber
das entscheidende der willensfreiheit
besteht in unseren willen der sagt und
nicht der vernunft und der wäre also ein
bisschen er auf ihrer seite und deswegen
hat er will frank wird auch viel kritik
bekommen zb von herrn professor nida
rümelin da hier lehrt dass gesagt es ist
falsch
das müsste gerade anders sein das
wesentliche der willensfreiheit besteht
unserer vernunft und ich bin habe ich
glaube es ist letztendlich ein streit um
worte wie wir es jetzt anhand dieser
formulierung sehen wir sehen naja gut
volition zweiter stufe ist schon
evolution gehört zum willen aber es ist
zweiter stufe ist also ein besonderer
wille eine reflexive wille ihr
selbstreflexion und reflexivität bilden
wir nur durch die vernunft aus und durch
sein vermögen was uns einfach ja zur
besinnung kommen lässt könnte man sagen
dass es eine rationalität in einem spiel
als wir sehen jetzt eigentlich darauf
kommt es nicht an dass wir gerade in
dieser wendung volition zweiter stufe
ausbilden sehen dass beide eigentlich
gar nicht sich so voneinander trennen
lassen als wenn sie wirklich willens
reid haben wollen müssen sie beide wille
und vernunft zusammenbringen ohne 1 nur
von beiden geht nicht sie können jetzt
natürlich noch sagen gegen die vernunft
ja nur mit loser vernunft da komme ich
nie zum handeln ich kann noch so viele
dinge erkennen wenn die vernunft nicht
trieb nicht
wird also unseren willen irgendwie in
gang setzt wenn da nicht noch eine
instanz ist die realisieren wirkt oder
verwirklichen taktiert so was wie eine
energie dann haben wir damit lose
überlegung zu tun tolle gedanken gemacht
hier und dort und so aber wir kommen die
zur handlung wir bleiben nur im raum und
zukunft im raum der gründe die gründe
selbst die während handlungs wirksam
damit also die gründe die reflexion die
erkenntnis handlungs dass die handlungs
gründe handlungs wirksam werden dazu
brauchen wir noch was dazu nämlich sagen
bilder zu mögen sowie kraft das auch zu
realisieren
und dann gibt es andere denker wie zb
immanuel kant immanuel kants akt was
sagt immanuel kant immanuel kants akt
der wille ist die vernunft
das sagt kann oder der reine wille ist
die reine vernunft also kannte
identifiziert die beiden kann zeigt die
vernunft als vernunft die ihr sind der
lage selbst aktiv zu sein kann dass die
praktische vernunft verkannten ist die
vernunft als solcher schon aufs
praktische gerichtet oder anders gesagt
die vernunft ist nach kann selbst etwas
was so eine energie in sich hat als eine
ganz umstrittene these würden sie sagen
dass die vernunft in sich so stark ist
dass sie unseren willen bestimmen kann
dass sie selbst auch zur handlung führen
kann nur die vernunft allein es gibt
natürlich so ein phänomen die zwingende
gründe zwingende gründe also die sie
haben so eine einsicht in einen grund
zusammenhang dass das so schlüssig ist
und so kohärent ist ihre überlegung dass
sich alles zu allem fühlt das sagen das
muss doch jetzt wirksam werden
mai
wir machen
ja ok hier haben guter punkt also an
dieser frage nach dem mitleid da wäre ja
wahrscheinlich mitleid das motiv ich
weiß es nicht sicher als an dieser frage
scheiden sich die geister
manche würden dieses beispiel als beleg
dafür bringt dass der wille das
entscheidend ist nicht die vernunft die
würden sagen wir leiden mit
unser wille leidet mit abo schopenhauer
die welt als wille und vorstellung in
dem wir jemanden anderen leiden sehen
wird unser wille der nur ein teil des
allgemeinen willen ist aktiviert und die
vernunft spielt überhaupt keine rolle
das würden also viele sagen sie würden
sagen beim mitleid oder in seiner
moralischen situation da spielt die
vernunft da keine rolle da handeln wir
einfach instinktiv aus mitleid heraus
dann gibt es aber andere wie zum
beispiel kant die würden sagen nein
dafür nehme ich meinen gewissen in mir
an gewissen oder das ist bei kant ganz
eng mit der vernunft verbunden
das gewissen der höre ich mir eine
innere stimme ein inneres gebot du
sollst dieser abend person helfen die
gotischen imperativ und dann entscheide
ich mich aus vernunftgründen aus
moralischen gründen heraus als das von
der person zu helfen kurze abstimmung
es ist eine offene debatte darüber war
es jetzt hier die gründe sind wer wir
das sagen das sind so einer beispiel
situation dass wir hier eine bedürftige
person sehen der mann der man helfen
muss wer würde von ihnen sagen dass hier
die wohnung der grund für die handlung
ist er würde sagen dass der wille das
mitleid ist ok und die anderen die
nichts gesagt an als würde ich sagen
gut sehr gut alle das wäre das ein guter
punkt sie würden also das wäre ein grund
für den willen oder sowas wie was ihr
emotionales auch villa und emotionen
sind natürlich enger verbunden als es
emotionen von 15
der williams begriff ist näher an der
emotion dran am gefühl an seinem
materialen gehalt als die vernünftige er
so ein bisschen abstrakt ist kant sagt
immanuel kants sagt nein
die vernunft selbst ist in der lage ein
eigenes gefühl hervorzubringen nämlich
das gefühl der achtung es kommt erkannt
aus der reinen vernunft heraus durch
hoch umstritten ob so etwas überhaupt
gibt
aber ich sag mal so die psychologie und
die empirischen wissenschaften würden
sicherlich sagen es sind willens
gründete emotionale gründe die uns und
zum intuitiven handeln bringen
aber es ist spannend und die frage ist
halt auch die handeln wir wenn wir
jemanden aus mitleid helfen unmittelbar
handeln wir dann überhaupt noch willens
frei oder handeln wieder nicht ihr
getrieben durch unser mitleid
unterliegen wir dann nicht halt einen
natur trieb oder einem trieb wenn wir
darüber gar nicht reflektieren sind wir
dann sagen wann moralische wann könnte
man sich fragen
das möchte kann eben gerade nicht sagen
kann würde sagen selbst moralisches
handeln in so eine situation ist immer
vernunft geleitet das handeln aber da
hat er natürlich das problem diese
spontanität hand gemessen zu fassen die
wir ja im band in situationen kennen das
kennen sie alle sehen eine situation und
in den allermeisten fällen handeln wir
in solchen situationen engagiert und
selbstlos in gewisser weise hat das ist
das kennt jeder von ihnen und ich glaube
auch dass da als phänomenologische
betrachtet die vernunft erstmal nicht so
eine große rolle spielt weil wie sie
richtig sagen wenn ich da groß anfangen
zu überlegen dann ist die person schon
gestorben unter umständen oder dann ist
das kind schon im brunnen gefallen
sozusagen also große debatte und es gibt
jetzt eben in der mittelalterlichen
diskussion zwei grob zwei positionen es
gibt dem wohl und tourismus dass sie
sagen ihm gerade das sind diese gründe
die dafür sprechen wir müssen den willen
betont und es gibt die den
intellektualismus
ein intellektuell ist ische freiheits
theorien eine wohnung touristische
freiheits theorie und wir werden jetzt
uns paradigmatisch zwei denkt anzuwenden
und zwar beginnen wir mal mit duns
scotus also diesem herrn hier
und der wird gemeinhin als ein toyota
rist aufgefasst während der andere
denker den wir heute noch lesen wollen
thomas von der queen deren tier das
halte der intellektuell ist zugeordnet
wir kommen noch auf ihn zu sprechen
das ist aus seiner schrift quest junis
sofern die büros mit der physik ohren
aristoteles alle das ist eben sind die
fragen über die metav die aristotelische
bücher der metaphysik und das ist eben
das neue buch gibt davon duns scotus
auch noch andere schriften aber ich habe
jetzt eben hier mal gewählt und wir
beginnen einfach mal mit dem ersten text
und zwar sagt er
die ausübung der eigenen tätigkeit kann
grundsätzlich nur auf zwei verschiedene
weisen geschehen entweder ist ein
vermögen von sich darauf bestimmt
daraufhin bestimmt tätig zu sein so dass
es von sich aus nicht fähig ist untätig
zu sein wenn es von außen unbehindert
ist oder es ist von sich aus nicht
bestimmt sein kann diesen faktoren
gegenteilige markt hervor bringen bzw
handeln oder nichthandeln das erste
vermögen wird gewöhnlichen natur genannt
das zweite will was ist jetzt noch nach
bones fotos natur
aber noch mal wiederholen das wärs ihr
vermögen das ist dieses bei entweder das
ein vermögen was von sich daraufhin
bestimmt tätig zu sein so dass es von
sich aus nicht fähig ist untätig zu sein
bild von außen also es ist ein vermögen
was von natur aus immer so handeln muss
immer ebenso bestimmten sinn eine weise
gibt es keine alternativen möglichkeiten
zu sagen das nennt jetzt die natur also
wesentliche bestimmt hat wesentliche
ausrichtung ab rio rische ausrichtung
auf eine option hin dass andere nennt er
den willen der wille ist als ein
vermögen
gegenteilige optionen zu wählen oder
nicht also mache ich die
entscheidungsfähigkeit
und jetzt wollen wir schauen wie sich
das verhältnis von natur was er unter
natur versteht und wille zur
unterscheidung zwischen villa und
vernunft
dementsprechend fällt der intellekt
innenbereich der natur ist nämlich von
sich aus determinierte verstehen und er
verfügt nicht darüber zu verstehen oder
nicht zu verstehen und was setzte
betrifft wo er zwar konträre akte haben
kann
erfüllt er dennoch nicht übersehen
nämlich ob er zustimmt oder nicht
wenn auch wie aristoteles offensichtlich
sagt einfache erkenntnis ab mit
gegenteiligen erkenntnis gegenständen zu
tun haben kann
so ist der inter legte nicht in bezug
auf diese erkenntnis von sich aus
unbestimmt vielmehr übt er diese
erkenntnis akten notwendigerweise aus
ebenso wie ihr notwendig einen anderen
erkenntnis hat ausüben würde der sich
nur auf einen einzigen erkenntnissen
stand bezogen
der wille hingegen verhält sich zur
ausübung seines eigenen akt auf
gegenteilige weise wie vorhergesagt
worden ist daher werden dementsprechend
in der trinität nur zwei produktionen
angenommen unter internet ist dasselbe
prinzip wie die natur in dem was
aristoteles hat scheint die erste
betrachtungsweise und berücksichtigt
also lassen sie mal die ganzen
referenzen auf aristoteles beiseite
betrachten wir man nur mal das argument
für sich was sagte jetzt über die
vernunft das ist jetzt sehr
aufschlussreich bei uns das noch ein
weiteres argument was er für die wohnung
touristen unter ihnen unter uns spricht
wozu gehört jetzt der intellekt und ist
ein bisschen paradox ist mal hier ist
das hat die von uns oder den intellekt
gehört in den bereich der natur
was ist daran jetzt erst mal kontra
intuitiv
ja
die
genau also es geht hier darum natur ist
der bereich wo es eine vollständige
determination am werk ist da sind wir
determiniert auf einen bereich eine
richtung und das sind wir in der natur
trieben nach heutiger sicht aber und
jetzt ist die entscheidung nach dem
skoda sind wir das auch eine natur die
vernunft ist praktisch auch determiniert
das praktisch so wir sind vernunft
determiniert darin sind wir ziemlich
eingeschränkt wir können immer nur das
gute tun also das was also das gute
denken wollen also dass wahrheit denken
wollen so die vernunft ist kein vermögen
des fehlers die verluste ist immer das
vermögen der erkenntnis also dass
richtigen das waren
der verlust ist nicht das vermögen das
falsche sagt jetzt uns fotos kleine
gerne bezug wieder auf immanuel kant
immer anerkannt sagt jetzt
interessanterweise ich bin darauf erst
auch vor kurzem bekommen so wie mir
scheint dass die vernünftigen nicht nur
die quelle des wahren ist sind auch die
quelle des falschen nämlich in seiner
dialektik wir werden darauf vielleicht
noch ein bisschen eingehen später wenn
wir jemanden aber kann sagt es gibt eine
dialektik der vernunft und dialektik ist
verkannt die logik des scheins also die
vernunft ist bei kant höchst ambivalent
und eben nach dieser definition nicht
der natur zuzuordnen weil sie nach kant
auch einen schein verfallen kann als
auch dass falsche auf das falsche
gerichtet ist und zwar von natur aus auf
dem schein nach kant denkt die vernunft
ideen wie die unsterblichkeit der seele
das ist verkannt eine vernunft idee die
die vernunft in sich notwendigerweise
hat aber die cd ist falsch oder
jedenfalls nicht begründet dass wir
glauben könnten auf vernünftige weise an
zur sterblichkeit zeigen auf
theoretische war
dass wir das theoretisch wie gewohnt das
ist falsch und die von uns trotzdem die
hat in sicht die idee dass wir
unsterblich sein kann löst dieses
problem in moralphilosoph scheint sich
aus aber aus theoretischer hinsicht
können wir die unsterblichkeit der seele
kann nicht beweisen nicht begründen wohl
idee der unsterblichkeit in unserer
fonds steckt das war von natur als da
ist bekannt die vernunft nicht nur auf
das wahre gerichtet ist sondern auch so
ein bisschen auf das falsche aber es nur
ein kleiner exkurs hier und gemeinhin
würde man sagen die vernunft als null
ist auf das wahre ausgerichtet auf die
das was wir begründen können und eben
nicht auf das falsche
wenn wir einen fehler machen in einem
mathematischen aufgaben würden wir
nichts sagen dass die vernunft hier
aktiv war
so etwas würden wir sagen was war mit
der fünfte fall als wir einen fehler
gemacht hat in einer mathematikaufgabe
wurde dann in der philosophischen
argumentation das würden sie dann sagen
wir müssen über die von hütter reden
damit wir diesen fehler begründen können
was war bei der fünfter fall überlegen
sie mal wenn sie jetzt einen fehler
machen
rechenfehler autos denkfehler
ist der fehler ein akt der vernunft
genau also ist ein defekt der vernunft
die vernunft hat versagt
das ist ein mangel ein defizit die
vernunft war da nicht am berg der
vernunft hatte einen hänger oder ein
aussetzer ich war da nicht ganz bei
verstand also dass ausgerechnet haben
oder als ich diese sind diese these vom
mieter da war ich nicht herr meiner
vernunft oder frau meiner von uns würde
man häufig sagen also die vernunft hat
da einfach nicht gewirkt
und ich frage ist kann die vernunft
ebenfalls hat selbst auch wirkt oder
wirkt sie bringen zieht das falsche
insofern hervor also eben im falschen
nicht wirkt eine prävention street als
ein mangel anfangen
man kannte wird das anders formuliert er
wird sagen so kann mir jedenfalls lesen
ich finde so sollte mal gelesen das auch
in falschen die vernunft wirkt so können
wir nur das falsche verstehen überhaupt
oder uns zu rechnen
überlegen sie mal folgenden fall jetzt
also sie haben etwas böses getan etwas
unmoralisches getan und werden dafür
jetzt angeklagt wenn sie jetzt an dem
richter sagen ja aber meine vernunft hat
er einfach ein aussetzer gehabt als ich
das tat
dh ich war dann nicht frei könnte der
intellektuell ist sagen als ich das
größte tat oder als ich zu schnell
gefahren bin auf der autobahn und jetzt
den strafzettel bekommen haben da hat
meine vernunft einfach ausgesetzt
und dafür kann ich nichts die vernunft
hat mich nicht geleitet
mich hat mein wille geleitet und diesem
moment als ich zu schnell gefahren
also ich hatte einen dicken vernunft
effekt in dieser zeit und weil die
vernunft nicht meine hand liegt entweder
ich bin halt vernünftig oder nicht bin
ich dafür nicht zu rechnen war
also will ich den strafzettel nicht
bezahlen die strafe bezahlt nicht was
könnten sie jetzt darauf antworten
gut
konsens ist es aber auch genauso gut
hätte keine folgen
gut
geschlossen
euro
das aufbauspiel aufwenden
gut ich glaube so müsste man es machen
also müsste dann sagen und jetzt kommt
wieder was anderes spiel irgendwie es
wird ein bisschen paradox war jetzt
müsste man sagen
man hat er nicht den willen aufbringen
können und vernunft anzuwenden
so müsste man ja einige argumentieren
also man hatte nicht grundsätzlich genug
konzentriert und konzentration fotos
eine frage ist es eine frage der
vernunft hätte man zwei vernunft
vernünftige sozusagen eine vernunft hat
versagt die antrag 50 gebrauchen da wird
schwierig müsste sagen unser wille war
der falsche wille wir hatten haben nicht
den willen aufgebracht die vernunft so
zu gebrauchen so einzusetzen dass sie
zur wahrheit führt also dann schiebt man
soll die ursache auf den willen wenn die
vernunft und aushänge aussetzer hatte
wird auf den willen geschoben so würde
es jeder richter oder jede richterin
bestimmt sagen sie haben so wie sie es
jetzt begründet haben sie waren zu
unkonzentriert sie haben sich nicht
richtig unter kontrolle gehabt und
kontrolle gut hat immer was mit 5 zu tun
aber letztendlich auch wenn will sie
haben ihre willensbildung nicht richtig
vollzog
es war egal sie war nachlässig also mir
scheinbar würde das kann er wieder auf
den willen schieben die villa hat die
vernunft nicht richtig kontrolliert
nicht richtig gebraucht wir hatten nicht
den willen die willensstärke die
vernunft einzusetzen und für unsere
willensstärke könnten wir jetzt nach
diskus verantwortlich sein weil nämlich
der wille immer auf zwei verschiedene
weisen gehen kann der wille ist ja nicht
die natur will er hat immer die
gegenteilige option
wir könnten also uns dafür entscheiden
ohne dagegen entscheiden die vernunft zu
gebrauchen
also liegt der grund dafür dass wir
jetzt die mathematik aufgabe nicht
richtig gemacht haben eben im village
der die vernunft nicht richtig gebraucht
hat
so könnte man ist das ganze
argumentieren text hat vielmehr ist der
wille gegenüber seinem eigenen akten
bestimmt und sei nach von selbst aus und
durch diese hat determiniert er den
intellekt hinsichtlich der
ursächlichkeit die der internet nach
außen hin hat das ist genau dieser punkt
die mischer also der wille der
determiniert die vernunft hier geht es
die richtung sozusagen nur vom willen
auf die vernunft also nur der pfeil von
links nach rechts der wille terminiert
die vernunft weil die vernunft kann ja
nur eine richtung
also muss der wähler der in verschiedene
richtungen kann die ursprünglich instanz
sein und der detaillierte jetzt klebt
select hält sich der ursächlichkeit
sollte ihnen das ein oder das könnte mir
jetzt zu rückfragen an den willen
könne zurückfragen ja aber bitte
genau woher nimmt der wille den seine
gründe oder sein motiv oder seine
prinzipien dass er die von uns so
gebraucht müssen diese prinzipien nicht
wiederum selbst aus der stadt will jetzt
doch an solche er blind also man könnte
sagen ein wille ohne vernunft ist blind
und eine vernünftige wille ist
vielleicht schwach oder
über den jetzt ist ist wie seiner seite
ist lahm oder genau ist ist eben schwach
oder sommer also es ist eben völlig
passiv aktiv als wir sehen jetzt
irgendwie muss wille und vernunft immer
zusammengedacht werden wir müssen auch
im willen immer schon irgendwie so ein
rest der von uns drin haben was wir eben
wenn wir wesentlich operieren dass wir
mit gründen will dich operieren steht
mit villen sowie harry friend wird da
wird sehr deutlich eine koalition
zweiter stufe wird glaube ich sehr
deutlich dass im reflexiven wollen immer
die vernunft mit drin ist das wäre
unvernünftig eigentlich gar nicht so
trennen lassen
das ist eine künstliche künstlich
isolieren und das in der vernunft selbst
eben auch immer so ein bisschen wille
drinsteckt vernunft hat auch interesse
der vernunft tritt nie nur ein operieren
fürchtet immer auf etwas gerichtet seien
erwünscht ist immer eine konkrete
vernunft es gibt nicht diese absolute
vernünftiger losgelöst von allen zwängen
operieren verlust ist immer verläuft an
etwas für etwas dann bestimmt kontext
und das deutet darauf hin dass sie immer
schon gerichtet ist ein gericht ist eben
durch den will
es geht nicht die abstrakte vernunft für
uns menschen die hier müsse hut und
schwebt eingebetteten konkrete situation
handlungskonzepts
so und jetzt schauen ob noch ein zitat
haben hier
wenn man aber unter rational mit mit
vernunft versteht dann ist der will im
eigentlichen sinne das rationale
vermögen
er bezieht sich nämlich auf
gegenteiliges sowohl hinsichtlich seines
eigenen als auch in bezug auf die akte
der untergeordneten vermögen er bezieht
sich auf gegenteiliges nicht auf
naturhafte weise wieder internet der
sich nicht selbst auf eine von zwei
alternativen möglichkeiten festlegen
kann so in freie weise da er sich selbst
bestimmen kann und daher ist ein
vermögen denn er selbst vermag etwas zu
tun
er kann sich nämlich selbst
determinieren der intellekt ist aber im
eigentlichen sinn kein vermögen
bezüglich deren wirkung denn er ist
selbst wenn er mit gegenteil zu tun hat
so also mit optionen alternativen
möglichkeiten so kann er sich doch nicht
selbst auf eine alternative festlegen
und sofern ähnlich detailliert wird hat
er nicht die fähigkeit nach außen hin
tätig zu sein
all das ist das argument der wohl und
touristen
die vernunft den trägt wenn er nicht mit
dem willen verbunden wird bleibt nur für
sich er wird nie die vernunft wird nie
handlungs wirksam
sie bleibt einpassen abstrakt das
spricht jetzt dafür dass du ins q4 ein
wohnung tourist ist aber wir können
jetzt hier wiederum sagen er sagt jetzt
der wille ist im eigentlichen sinn dass
rational vermögen also hier kommt jetzt
plötzlich irgendwie die von uns wieder
rein ist ein bisschen paradox was ist
daran paradox
das sagte wille ist das rationale
vermögen ja
genau also wir hatten also wenn wir
jetzt sagen die ratio ist sei die
vernunft er übersetzt jetzt hier das
rational mit 15 müssen jetzt natürlich
das lateinische schauen haben sie den
text gerade da das lateinische dh die
deutsche übersetzung könnte jetzt
vielleicht falsch sein
das wird sagen müssen vernünftig also
hier wäre es jetzt andersherum hier wäre
jetzt eben ratio vernunft und nicht
intellektuell verläuft ja das ist
allemal ein problem aber an und noch ein
wichtigeres problem scheint mir das zu
sein das ja eigentlich das vernünftige
sei es jetzt dass die intellektuell oder
die rad zu ja eigentlich der natur zum
com lässt ihr letztes der natur zur
natur zu kommen und jetzt sagt er
plötzlich der wille sei ein rationales
vermögen ist ein bisschen paradox ist
der wille jetzt ein natürliches vermögen
international meint kultur zu kommen
stehen sie es ein bisschen wie ein
bisschen seltsam
also dass jetzt wieder rational nimmt
während doch davor gesagt hatte dass die
internet-router spricht er vom intellekt
muss man vielleicht auch noch ein
bisschen berücksichtigt dass der
intellekt in die natur gehört und jetzt
spricht er nicht mehr vom dialekt
sondern von der vernunft eines könnte es
sein dass der übersetzer für
ratio als er für den verstand was wir
jetzt als verstand mehr zeit haben um
begriff von uns gebraucht und für die
vernunft
also von intellekt uzh das wort
intellekt also eine verschiebung also
statt vernunft sagt er jetzt übersetzte
intellekt und stadt verstand sagt er
vernunft wie auch immer den blick ist
eben das höhere vermögen und dann könnte
man sagen gut dann haben wir eben eine
andere form von rationalität eher sowas
wie die rad zu also das diskursive
vermögen und das diskursive vermögen ist
ja gerade das was eben gründe ermöglicht
und dann wird ein schuh draus wenn sie
das mal überlegen weil es ist ja nicht
der intellekt dass nicht die
intellektuelle wille intellektuelle
wille wäre so ein bisschen widerspruch
weil der ja eigentlich immer nur in eine
richtung kann
der intellekt ist immer gerichtet das
natur und auf die wahl
jetzt haben wir hier aber eine rationale
willen also praktisch nicht mehr
intellektuellen willens international
fühlen das heißt das könnte ein weg sein
der mit dem diskursiv verstandes
vermögen in verbindung steht und das
diskursive verstandes vermögen erlaubt
ebenso was mit abwägungen zu treffen
das ist wie instrumentelle vernunft hat
kann jemand noch mal den lateinischen
satz vorlesen lesen einfach mal habe ich
ihn nicht auch mit rum geschickt hat wie
man das lateinische gerade vor sich
also da mehr rational ist es am ende als
ratio ist der verstand
hier wird es mit vernunft ersetzt weil
eben vernunft dort mit intellekt ersetzt
und es würde so ein bisschen passend
dass wir sagen haben eben zur zwei
formen der vernunft oder des
intellektuellen der intellekt tus als
vernunft wie wir sie zu besetzen als das
was der natur zu gehört weil eben die
vernunft nur auf die wahrheit
ausgerichtet ist und dann haben wir auch
den verstand und der verstand ist so
eine niedrigere form von vernunft und
von rationalität und der ist das was
platin als diana bezeichnet das ist das
diskursive vermögen damit können wir
eben wieder so ein bisschen flexibilität
hineinbringen und sind nicht mehr nur
getrimmt auf die wahrheit sprich auf die
natur bezogen da haben wir dann seine
flexibilität und die erlaubt es uns eben
diese form von rationalität mit dem
willen und seiner nicht natürlichen
verfasstheit in verbindung zu bringen
das würde also etwas passen da würde
jetzt eine art von verbund stattfinden
in dem eben der wille sowas rationales
ist demgegenüber ist der wille egal ob
er sich auf diese oder jene
handlungsalternative richtet kein von
sich aus der termin das prinzip seiner
tätigkeit vielmehr hat er die fähigkeit
sich selbst auf eine von beiden
alternativen festzulegen das kann sich
fragen mit welchen grünen dann legt er
sich denn fest muss da nicht eben schon
wieder ein moment der vernunft ins spiel
kommen
es ist anders so ferne sich nämlich dem
potenzial nach auf gegenteiliges bezieht
bezieht er sich zwar zugleich auf
gegenteiliges aber nicht auf
gegenteiliges zugleich denn er verhält
sich zu ihnen nicht auf naturhafte weise
so dass er sich auf beide alternativen
nacheinander festlegen kann und daher
tut er dies auch also er ist frei was in
alternativen anbelangen
und sofern ein willensakt zb ein war
kein urteil über das zu wählende frau
ersetzt kann eine handlungsalternative
durch andere mittels der eben
beschriebenen erkenntnis art erkannt
werden
dennoch will der wille gelegen nicht
gegen dieses urteil jetzt auch noch
interessant und diesem urteil könnte
wieder dieses atrium liebe rumliegen und
wenn jetzt der wille immer dem urteil
des wählenden folgen würde dann wäre der
wille eigentlich natur dann wäre er
nicht mehr flexibel
das heißt wir können uns selbst gegen
vernünftige urteile willentlich noch mal
entscheiden
und das finde ich es ganz wichtig dass
wir vielleicht wie handeln wider
besseres wissen frage ist ob das in form
von willensschwäche oder acacia ist ich
glaube es jetzt noch nicht aber hier
wird eben klar dass der wille immer
diese flexibilität hat auf beide
alternativen offenkundig richtet sich
also ein vermögen als welches der wille
gilt nicht insofern auf alternativen als
ist sie gleichzeitig für wirken kann
sondern sofern sich auf eine von beiden
festlegen kann
beim intellektuell intellekt ist das
nicht so das haben wir schon gehört und
legend ist die vernunft
kam noch ein paar zutaten
deshalb sage ich dass intellekt der
aktuellen objekt erkennt mit dem willen
als wird ursache bei der verursachung
seines willens zusammenwirkt und
entsprechend ist kurz gesagt die natur
die aktuell das objekt erkennt und frei
ist die ursache des wollens oder des
widerwillens darin besteht nämlich die
wahlfreiheit das andere spannende
formulierung die natur die aktuell das
objekt erkennt und frei ist
verstehen sie dass die natur
die natur ist ja eigentlich jetzt wieder
die vernunft
aktuell bedeutet eben nicht generell
universal sind auf eine bestimmte
situation also es geht ja alles um form
der rationalität die sehr konkret
studiert ist und frei bedeutet eben dass
sie diese flexibilität hat auf beide
zeit nehmen
es bleibt aber immer noch ein bisschen
dunkel
der wille ist aber die maßgebende
ursache und die erkennen die natur die
weniger maßgebende denn der wieder
bewegt frei und entsprechend dieser
bewegung bewegt er etwas anderes und
determiniert es insofern zu dessen
tätigkeit die natur die das objekt
erkennst amateurhaft tätiges das was
sein beitrag betrifft immer tätig ist es
kann allerdings nie in weil ich zur
ausübung des akt sein wenn der wille
nicht zusammen wirkt und insofern ist
der wille die maßgebende hre ursache
also hier ist ein ganz klares statement
für den wohl und tourismus duns scotus
ist ein prototypischer montag ist er
sieht zwar dass wir die von uns immer
brauchen um uns zu entscheiden aber er
sagte wille ist das maßgebende usa das
heißt die vernunft ist schon auch ein
bisschen eine ursache aber der wille ist
eben die maßgebend was sagt als er würde
sagen hier so weil diese eine aktive
geht so tendenziell auf die seite des
willens würde eher sagen
bezogen auf unsere debatte eher wird er
sagen ich bin sondern hier suzuki und
nicht ganz hier habe ich bin so hier
ich bin kein purer volontär ist ich sehe
da kommt die 53 aber ich bin tendenziell
auf der seite des willens
jetzt möchte ich ihnen natürlich den
antrag wir springen jetzt ein paar
zitate
das können sie alles ich habe die folien
auf die lowcost gestellt die können sie
sich herunterladen auch über die app
oder über die homepage er sagte jetzt
zwar noch mal so dass die willens sei
die bei vermögen erfasst nämlich den
intellekt und den willen
es ist nicht so dass nur der wille ist
kombination der blick also mit dem
rationalen vermögen als ein förmige
ursache zusammen und gibt rennt sind sie
jeweils nur entfernte ursache daher ist
das rationale vermögen zusammen mit dem
determinieren den willen eine
wesentliche ursache des akts gemeinsam
zu wollen
das rationale vermögen ist also gerade
jetzt nicht die vernunft eines rationale
vermögen ist der wille der eben
erschienenen gegen gesetzte richtungen
geben wollen kann er bringt nicht die
indifferente wieder die wirkung hervor
sache wieder der sich selbst bestimmen
selbst bestimmen findet nur statt mit
vernunft durch gebrauchte von das ist
keine bloße will kein bloßer
indifferente sind aber tendenziell ist
der wille den scheitel stunts
so und jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten
denkern jetzt kommen wir zu thomas von
aquin und thomas von der queen ist
gerade ein vertreter der
entgegengesetzten position thomas von
aquin wird in der geschichte der
philosophie der seite der intellektuell
ist zugerichtet als er sagt nicht der
wille ist das maßgebende sondern von ihm
stammt das zitat die wurzel aller
freiheit ist die vernunft also radix sie
kennen alle radieschen radix ist die
wurzel des libertés ratio oder intellekt
ich weiß es nicht wie genau die
technologie ist und er hat ein werk
geschrieben die soma theologie und noch
eine schrift die veritate über die
wahrheit
ja ich habe immer mit meinen mit meinen
jahreszahlen problem sie haben völlig
recht ich habe immer in meinen seminaren
die jahres ein problem das ist jetzt
schon so häufig vorgekommen aber es ist
sehr gut dass sie sagen ich würde es für
die youtube version korrigieren na
schauen wir noch mal hier habe ich
bestimmt was falsch aber noch mehr er
hat auch noch alles deutlich älter
geworden haben
das wäre es ein wirkliches er wunderkind
himmel also er hat auch noch ein anderes
werk verfasst nämlich wie muss es
richtig lauten
achja 25 jahre schon mal ist der dienst
12 55 gestorben das könnte sein
nein auch nicht nennen habe ich es
falsch geschrieben werden vielen dank
also und jetzt gehen wir zu einem
rationalisten über nämlich zu thomas von
aquin
hier ist er noch mal und jetzt es gibt
noch eine weitere schrift die auch noch
wichtig wäre dass die schrift die mal
als über das böse
malo buch nummer sechs aber das wollen
wir heute nicht ins zentrum stellen
sondern einfach mal schrift die veritate
und da sagte folgendes der wille und die
vernunft nämlich schließen sich
gegenseitig gewissermaßen ein
denn der wille will dass die vernunft
erkennen und die vernunft hat zum
erkenntnis gegenstände den willen so ist
also zu alter ist in den dingen wie ich
als gegenstand des willens darstellen
auch das als etwas begehrenswertes
enthalten was gegenstand der vernunft
ist und umgekehrt
deshalb verhält sich im bereich des
begehrenswerten des guten die wahrheit
wie ein besonderes gut und das gute
überhaupt alles das allgemein
und umgekehrt daraus also dass die
wahrheit ein einzelnes besonderes gut
ist folgt dass das gute in bereiche des
begehrens werden früher weil allgemeiner
ist nicht aber folgt dass es ohne
beitritt voraussetzung unbedingt früher
in der auffassung sein
als er hatte sie den bereich das
begehrenswerten und er hat den bereich
des verfassungs konnte man mal schauen
weiß und ich haben sie das lateinische
gerade da was er jetzt mit auffassung
übersetzt vielleicht übersetzt sogar
vielleicht ist sogar hier dieses wort
intellektuell nicht sicher kann man mal
später mal ein bisschen nachprüfen
ich glaube ich habe es auch gegeben noch
als lateinische zitate also was sagte
jetzt hier über das verhältnis von
beiden wie verhalten sich zueinander
und wie und warum
das sieht doch jetzt ersten also danach
aus dass er hier so eine art synthese
machen möchte möchte diesen mittelweg
gehen haben wir auch schon bei duns
scotus gesehen also diese ganzen einen
pauschalen klassifizierungen entweder
wohl unter gehst oder entweder
intellektuell ist im meistens nie
es gibt immer irgendwelche zwischen also
irgendwie spielt immer beides eine rolle
beides jedes vermögen bis an dem freien
willensakt beteiligt es ist eher so eine
frage der akzent setzen wo es stärker
den akzent auf
hier hört sich jetzt doch erst mal so an
als ob das ungleichgewicht herrscht nun
also wieder unvernunft die sind beide
gleichermaßen beteiligt und zwar finde
ich sehr aufschlussreich ist der zweite
denen der wille will dass die vernunft
erkenne und die vernunft hat zum
erkenntnis gegen stunde den willen also
ihr beispiel vor was ich gebracht hatte
mit dem schnellen geschwindigkeit oder
mit der mathematik aufgabe wir müssen
auch den willen haben zu erkennen als in
der materie wenn sie in mathe klausur
schreiben was sie wahrscheinlich jetzt
nicht mehr machen müssen aber wenn sie
es müssten oder als sie es machen
mussten mussten sie den willen haben die
vernunft richtig zu gebrauchen und beim
gut es gibt sicherlich fälle wo einfach
unvermögen da ist wenn man einfach nicht
aufs ergebnis kommt man hat sich so
angestrengt den willen so herbeigeführt
und in stellung gebracht sagt jetzt mal
gut trotzdem will die vernunft will das
wahlergebnis ausspuckt dann ist es
tatsächlich ein unvermögen ja beim
zimmer einfach nicht intelligent genug
das gibt es natürlich auch im alltag der
alltag ist ja keine matheaufgaben der
alltag ist keine matheklausur sind der
alltag kommt aus mit relativ bezahlen in
form von kratzern
das in die kalkulation ziemlich ich sag
mal ziemlich niedrigschwellig müssen wir
müssen schlüsse ziehen im alltag mit den
schlussfolgerungen ziehen müssen
argumentieren müssen ableiten können
aber nicht auf dem hohen
abstraktionsgrad wieder in mathematik
losgesagt jetzt hier also die beiden
schließen sich gegenseitig ein als wir
müssten jetzt hier um diese ganze sache
korrekt darzustellen müssen wir jetzt
hier nach thomas von aquin hier so ich
mache das jetzt mal so ich mache das
jetzt mal mit zu einer schleife trübung
also die sind miteinander verwoben
also der wähler will dass die vernunft
erkenne das ist eine mathematikaufgabe
viele würden sagen ja eine
mathematikaufgabe da liegt die vernunft
einfach los dann war woher weiß denn die
vernunft dass sie jetzt loslegen so war
weiß die vernunft dass ich jetzt diese
aufgabe lösen soll und ich diese das
heißt der wille eine andere instanz muss
der vernunft irgendwie etwas vorgeben
das heißt das ist dass die seite von dem
willen in richtung vernunft der wille
will der villen lenkt die vernunft auf
bestimmte objekte und es gibt auch noch
die andere richtung nämlich hier wohl
sagt und die vernunft hat zum erkenntnis
gegenstand den willen
aha wie kann man das verstehen
liefern kann die vernünftigen erkenntnis
den wählern zum bekenntnis gegenstand
haben
okay wäre das aber dann nicht ihr doch
die richtung noch vom willen aufgekommen
ruft aber jetzt ja so ein bisschen also
schon richtig aber also wir haben jetzt
ja die einrichtung haben jetzt ja wir
sind jetzt ja der wille will dass die
vernunft erkenne das ist jetzt brauchte
schon wille zur vernunft von links nach
rechts
wir müssen uns fragen wie hat die
vernunft den willen zum erkenntnis
gegenstand also wie wie ist jetzt diesel
diese richtung zu verstehen meinten sie
dass ein beispiel
[Musik]
okay okay ja ich denke das geht in die
richtige richtung
ja ich dachte jetzt an folgendes an
harry frankfurt wieder wenn wir unseren
willen wählen also wenn wir sagen
volition zweiter stufe haben und dann
den richtigen willen wählen müssen
sozusagen wohl einfach nicht richtig von
wählen spricht also muss ich irgendwie
vernunft anstrengen um den richtigen
willen heraus zu finden oder so so lese
ich das ein bisschen wir können den
willen an reflektieren was sonst ein
reflektierter will diese position
zweiter stelle so interpretiere ich das
jetzt aber soll ich ganz klar war
vielleicht wird es klarer mit dem was er
dann nach st so ist als in den dingen
weg als gegenstand des winds da stimmt
auch das als etwas begehrenswertes
enthalten was gegenstand der vernunft
ist und umgekehrt
deshalb verhält sich im bereich des
begehrenswerten das gute die wahrheit
wie ein besonderes gut dass gute
überhaupt als das allgemeine umgekehrt
also die wahrheit ist jetzt natürlich
das was objekt der vernunft ist also die
wahrheit selbst tritt auch zu einem gut
als wir können die wahrheit eben wollen
also das objekt der vernunft ist die
wahrheit
und wir können das wahre wollen zb eine
mathematikaufgabe zulässig
erst einmal weiter die willens bewegung
motors um wohl und hat ist eine art hin
neigung im kino in etwas und wie etwas
natürlich heißt weil es der neigung der
naturgemäß ist in key nationen naturell
origination natur ist so heißt deswegen
auch etwas willentlich weil es der
neigung in china zu des willens gemäss
ist
war seine hin neigung in etwas
das ist aus der summer theologie dass
sie mal sehen hier also dass die
abkürzung zur theologie
das ist die kreation die frage
ich antwortete dass von einem dinge in
doppelte beziehungen ausgesagt wird es
setzte in bewegung einmal wie ein
vorgelegter zweck bewegt und bestimmt
und diese weise bewegt die vernunft den
willen denn das von der vernunft
aufgefasste gut ist der gegenstand und
bewegt diesen als der zweck
ok also
der vorgelegte zweck bewegt den willen
das heißt der zweck muss vielleicht erst
mal erkannt werden also wir kennen den
zweck wir wollen etwas
wir wollen etwas bei uns die punkte
nämlich sagt dass das gut ist dann
bewegt dieses dieser zweck die vernunft
man könnte natürlich noch folgendes
sagen wenn wir an bestimmten zweck haben
in dieser zeit könnte jetzt auch ihr den
willen zuzurechnen seien
dann kommt die von uns dann ins spiel
wenn es darum geht die mittel zu finden
diesen zweck zu erreichen
das ist glaube ich eher der übliche weg
jones liefern und im verhältnis zum film
vorstellen und zweck heftig kalt ist
etwas was eigentlich den willen zukunft
also ein teller
[Applaus]
dann aber wird und ausführen und
tatsächlich einwirkenden ausgesagt er
setzt in bewegung wie die wärme zum
beispiel weg welche den zustand eines
dinges ändert zum essen oder jener
welcher den stein weiter treibt und in
dieser weise bewegt der wille die
vernichtung aller anderen sälen kräfte
aha also jetzt erstmal den vorherigen
zitat geht es darum dass die vernunft
den willen bewegt in der weise des
vorgelegten zwecks so bewegt die
vernunft den willen da ist das ziel da
ist der zweck
das als tellers der zwecklos finis
wahrscheinlich glauben müssen wir noch
mal nachschauen was ist drexler also
ziel ein zustand das sagte jetzt dass er
jetzt gehe alles konzeptuelles
konzeptuell aristoteles das ist die form
ursache oder die zweck und sein wird man
sagen nichts wächst sie kennen doch alle
bei aristoteles die verursachen also
causa material ist causa effizienz ist
die wirkung sache das ist wenn ich mich
harnisch sozusagen ein wirke auf etwas
wie eine stadt wie ein steinmetz eine
statue haut eine form in einem stein
hineinbringt das ist die wirklichkeit
die materielle ursache die causa
material ist der statue aus stein ist
natürlich der stein dann gibt es noch
eine causa formal ist das ist dann
letztendlich die form in die der stein
gebracht wird nämlich in den staaten
fahren zb irgendwie ein diskuswerfen und
dann gibt es zum schluss noch die causa
finalist das ist dann die zweck
ursächlichkeit wozu wird denn überhaupt
die statue mit dieser konkreten form aus
diesem konkreten material wirklich
hergestellt nämlich um zum beispiel eine
schöne villa zu dekorieren
das eingangsportal einen schönen villa
schöner zu gestalten und das wäre dann
der zweck aber man könnte jetzt sagen ja
gut aber diese villa schöner zu
gestalten ist da ich mein wille den
zweck ein bisschen ausprobieren weil sie
ein konzept ist um plan nichts konkret
ist einfach so ein ziel es ist schwebt
uns vor ist eine idee ich hab da so eine
vision ich möchte hier mit denen diese
villa bauer mit dieser schönen statue
er sagte dass er die vernunft sagt ich
habe gerade ich möchte ich
ist es nicht eher was man will ja gut
aber der wille ist doch sehr konkret die
tatsache dass ein abstract das ziel
formulieren kann so verstehe ich jetzt
thomas von aquin das deutet darauf hin
dass es in die vernunft ist als die
vernunft weg den will insofern sieben
ziele setzt konzeptuelle oder pläne
schmiedet die dann zu führen und
andersherum wenn ich recht verstehe
sagte der weg geht es der wille die
vernunft sowie ein stein bearbeitet wird
all das ist die causa effizienz das ist
also eine sehr konkrete einwirkung der
widerwille die vernunft bewegt
weiter die vernunft erkennt das wollen
des willens gute wille will das erkennen
der vernunft das ist praktisch in aller
kürze so die hauptaussage hier die
verkennt dass wolltest mich ist es ein
bisschen sektor da wurde schon so ein
bisschen also reflexivität und der wille
bilderserie fünf jahre darin zeigt sich
dass beide wieder sehr eng miteinander
verwoben sind und ähnlich ist das gute
im waren enthalten als etwas wahres wie
das waren guten enthalten ist als ein
besonderes ereignis gut dass
veranstaltet das glaube ich alle mal
sehr schön
das gute ist waren enthalten als etwas
wahres wie das waren guten enthalten ist
als anders an das ereignis gut wenn wir
wollen also immer etwas weil es auch
wahr ist also weil es irgendwie unserer
vernunft entspricht uns gemäß unseres
letztendlich unangemessen erscheint
adäquat wenn wir von etwas
erstrebenswerten reden dann würde thomas
sagen dann ist das erstrebenswerte immer
erstrebenswert weil es intellektuell
erstrebenswert ist und weil es eben auch
erstrebenswert ist wesentlich weil es
eben ein gut ist nachdem wir streben es
aber nur ein gut weil es irgendwie auch
als gut erkannt es geht zur hand in hand
genau der gegenstand der vernunft ist
nun einfacher umfassender und
unbedingter wie der des willens
denn der gegend vernünftigste innere
grund im bewegt werden warum es geben
begehrenswert ist der wille aber richtet
sich auf das begehrenswerte guten grund
in der vernunft ist einfacher unbedingte
und vom einzelnen losgelöste aber etwas
ist desto höher steht es im range um ihn
darüber dass eine science alter ist
seiner natur nach das vermögen der
vernunft edler und erhabener wie das des
willens da haben wir es also während
duns scotus hier war ist thomas von
aquin hier nicht ganz auf der seite der
vernunft sondern tendenziell warum
können sie nochmal angeschlossen gerade
das argument nachvollziehen warum ist
die vernunft nach thomas von aquin
erhabener als der wille
weiter will immer noch was bestimmtes
geht was konkretes und die vernunft über
den grund dieses wählen es gibt also
immer das prinzip unseres denn es gibt
man könnte das vielleicht auch so
formieren wie die maximen das ist
interpretations versuchen die maxime
unsere grundsätze das sind
handlungsleitend die grundsätze die ich
auch durch vernunft gebildet hat das
werden zb sec and order wohlig das
könnte man sagen das hängt auch order
wurde dies würde die britin als sein
dass die rationalen grund setze die uns
unser leben strukturieren unsere
leitlinien unsere vernünftigen
grundsätze und die sind immer der
konkrete die sind immer der abstrakte
grund oder der basis für jedes konkrete
wollen was sich nach einem solchen
prinzip richtet so könnte man vielleicht
interpretieren und deswegen ist nach
thomas von aquin die vernunft erhalten
als der wille
ja das ist es für die heutige sitzung
wir haben heute ein parforce-ritt
unternommen durch zwei der wichtigsten
mittelalterlichen denker die den wohl
und tourismus tendenziell und den
intellektualismus tendenziell vertreten
sie haben gesehen wenn man genau
hinschaut je genauer hinschauen desto
eher sehen wir dass in beiden positionen
immer auch das andere vermögen im spiel
ist es gibt ja letztendlich nur
akzentsetzungen es ist keine es sind
keine essentiell ist ischen positionen
die sich ausschließen sondern sind ihr
graduelle formen
ich sagte akzentsetzung der einzelnen
vermögen die das leichte übergewicht
haben oder perspektive
das ist jetzt insofern wichtig als jetzt
der begriff der vernunft stärker ins
ziel kommt er ins spiel kommt als es
vielleicht bei den vorherigen denkern
der fall war
wir werden jetzt wenn ich mich nicht
irre in der nächsten sitzung uns mit
leibniz befassen wenn wir nicht ganz
täusche und dann werden wir mit großen
schritten auf immanuel kant zu gehen der
eine der wichtigsten denker der freizeit
ist und wir werden noch weitere denke
mit den zu ziehen nämlich wie sie sich
gewünscht haben auch noch schon konzerte
in seiner schrift das sein und das
nichts